[Music]
sup guys mkbhd here welcome back to
January so last year we did this thing
where I did a Q&A video every month one
video every month that's 12 Q&A is
during the year and we kind of got into
a rhythm and I feel like it was a good
idea we introduced a couple different
concepts and overall I enjoyed it so
we're doing it again this year for 2018
I'm getting the year right this time
so I already asked you guys on Twitter
what you guys wanted to know so without
any further ado let's let's get into it
we got a special guest Tesla Model 3 oh
and Austin Evans here so we'll just go
ahead and tag-team this one let the car
answer the question let's get started
what's a trend you do not want to see in
tech and 2018 don't want to see the easy
answer that I think a lot of people
would give is headphone jacks going away
stop oh yeah broccoli it's already over
ya have phone jacks pretty much dead at
this point that battle has been lost I
think a lot of people don't like to hear
that but we still need to see a wireless
technology get better I talked about
that in my last video
oh yeah the airplane video that was
great yeah so I don't know I I kind of
just I like the way a lot of things are
going right now now Daniel wants to know
same question but the opposite what's
the trend that you do want to see in
2018 I feel like I want to see
smartphones continue to get better and
more importantly cheaper I think that
we're getting to a point where $100 can
get you a surprisingly decent phone
especially we get to like two or three
hundred bucks I mean the gap between a
budget phone it's more like a flagship
is shrinking every year and I like to
see that that's a legit trend this year
we have an abundance of less expensive
phones oh my got another model three
that's crazy
look at one place on earth where model
threes you never expect that I'd like to
see a better usage of dual cameras maybe
play with focal lengths a little more
yeah I feel like right now most of the
time a dual cameras like oh it's
monochrome or it's like oh it's gonna
give you like some death data but like
you said the pixel kind of does a lot of
that stuff better already just like
what's the point of adding a second
camera unless it's doing something
meaningfully different I don't know who
I'm quoting but I know at one point a
youtuber has told me I don't think
anyone knows what the hell they're doing
with dual cameras that sounds like a
quote I can believe that not normal tech
related and this is true if you could
replace any body part with a cybernetic
replacement what would you choose and
why so this guy's fishing for a very
specific oh yeah
yeah yeah do you know who we are
what's your highest killcount pub gee I
don't like bleep up geez like one yeah I
think my answer is the same only the
second time I played I'd survived down
to like top 45 top 43 respect and I
found someone that I want to go shoot
and I had a gun that I knew nothing
about and I just pointed and squeezed a
bunch of times but it had this recoil
thing going on oh yeah every time you
shoot your aim just goes further and
further up but I didn't let it go back
down seems like I am squeezed and ended
up firing a lot of bullets into the sky
and I'm just like what's video doing
Pawel yeah I died pretty quick there
that's a good story yeah what what
health tracking apps are you using I'm
not really using many apps for that what
I try to do and I'm even wearing it but
I try to close all the Rings on my Apple
watch every single day which I lowered
my goals to I don't even know it's like
half of what it was supposed to be but
I'd do it if you want to answer feel
free to go through the tweets dig
through and find any good ones I have
another one with a weird rumor that came
up what are your thoughts on the rumors
about iPhone 10 being discontinued I
heard rumors and I don't I don't trust
it i don't I'll believe it when I see it
but there's a rumor that iPhone 10 as a
series has come and gone and it's not
gonna be a thing anymore we'll go back
to when they say that they mean like you
know at the end of September or whatever
when they bring out the iPhone 11 or
whatever the next one would be they were
just completely discontinued the ten
right well that makes sense to some
degree because they pretty much always
take the flagship phone and they bump it
down in praise but they'd have to bump
into ten down a lot in praise so I can
see them just basically clearing them
out putting the 11 and doing something
like the lower-cost version because it's
hard to imagine this foam being like 500
bucks I'll be honest I read the
headlines and I didn't consider any
logistical possibility of it happening
so I'll read into them more but that's
something new that's on my radar so
we'll see all right one okay should I
will bring back the 17-inch MacBook Pro
if they do do you think they'd stick
with AMD graphics or NVIDIA something
like a max Q 1070 just the general
question I would love to see another
17-inch MacBook Pro I do a lot of mobile
video editing times like this when we're
out here
la times like CES times like Mobile
World Congress in a month where I'm
bringing a lot of heavy footage and it
chokes my MacBook Pro every time do you
think you would see a significant
performance increase with a 17 because
I'm thinking of like laptop processors
and I mean the 15 already has about as
good as it gets on the laptop side
unless you look crazy like a desktop
which is gonna like eat through the
battery do you think you'll be
legitimately faster he thinks more
there's nothing like on the graphic
Snyder so I do think the GPU is what
you'd get the most out of having that
extra space with the battery could be a
bit bigger but thermally you can just do
more with the GPU with more space that's
pretty clear so yeah and Apple would
never do this but I would love to see
them unashamedly just make a thick just
video editing look at a screen 3 Delta
Pro it's never gonna happen but I'd love
to see that ok this is one I don't think
you're gonna be able to answer when I
try it anyway what do you think of black
mirror have you ever watched the Netflix
original series now black mirror I have
never watched black mirror I have a
Netflix account and it has probably
logged three total hours in its
existence hello people don't believe me
when I say that but I watch a lot of
YouTube yeah so I'm aware of the concept
that I understand when people reference
black mirror which is weird but I've
never watched it I would actually say
that you would play enjoy black man yeah
I would I would venture guess that it's
a very futuristic show it's about how
technology is gonna ruin everyone's
lives
oh you're entertaining who do you think
will be first Samsung Apple Google etc
to implement the on-screen fingerprint
sensor okay so I guess the first of the
big the big dawgs
big mainstream phone makers I would okay
so I would expect Samsung Samsung tends
to be the first they were you know they
they pushed the boundaries with things
like the iris scanner you know they try
new stuff so yeah Samsung I think would
be my thing like the note like nine or
something no nine note ten I mean Galaxy
S nine is coming out and I think that's
a little early to see it yeah I think
that would be interesting what are the
key iPhone and Mac apps that you rely on
and how has that changed over the last
12 months oh for sure one that comes
recently to mind Twitter for Mac trash
okay
oh I've used it but I use it for years I
now use Tweetbot on all my iOS and and
Mac's but I couldn't like if you've ever
tried to use Tweetbot for Mac for more
than five minutes in your Twitter format
Twitter from a cow it slows to a crash
thank you for correcting me yeah
let's agree on that section tweet vitals
awesome but uh yeah I have a pretty
study workflow across my it's a final
cut editing suite it's it's Spotify for
music Safari so yeah that's pretty much
my exact setup
I think Photoshop is thrown in there
sometimes but for the most part yeah
it's pretty much final cut Twitter
Safari Chrome Spotify like that's kind
of yeah for that up the core suite yeah
now let's change for me lately it's one
you may or may I want answer okay do you
have a Tesla referral code why mark is I
would love to buy a Tesla would you ever
have a referral code so I could do you
can't get anything for that or now I do
so funny story I do have a Tesla furro
code I've never really shared it I have
a couple friends who have bought a car
and so they wanted to have her referral
code and when you use a referral code to
buy a Tesla you get free supercharging
on your car for life so it is worth
something I'll put it in the description
I don't usually share it but well you do
get out of that as a referrer is every
new referral for me and the tier I'm in
right now is 2% off my final payment on
the roads
oh so basically if enough people click
the link in the description and sign up
with your referral code Gately a lot of
money off your roadster it's not gonna
happen but your 2% for roadster that's a
lot of money if you do the math it's
worth it yeah like 2% so yeah up to
literally 100 percent off I think I
think one Tesla based youtuber I'll
confirm with him but he has already
earned a free roadster was regrettable
yeah that's crazy okay you know what
that's a good question someone says what
are your thoughts on the new Hasselblad
I tweeted it earlier there's a new
Hasselblad h 6d
I'm gonna get this wrong h 6d 400 C
m/m/c it's a long name but essentially
it's a hundred megapixel sensor that's
using a multi shot so I think that's M s
that's taking 400 megapixel stills at
this point so normal stills are 100 mega
pixels you can you take multiple shots
to combine them it's combining them all
with like a one pixel difference
shifting in each direction
it's an insane technology but if I'm
printing billboards
that's something I'm into but I'm not so
I'll stick with stick with the camera I
use now it's like a normal Hasselblad
yeah just you know x1d is cool no big
deal
I think you may be
answer this one before if you didn't
have YouTube where do you think you
would be right now yeah I never know I
never know the answer I'll stop back at
you because I like have been making
videos for such a long part of my life
yeah that I mean I assumed I would do
something related to my major in college
which was business but I think the same
boat there because I think we started me
like what 1516 sometime so I think for
me I would probably be working at Best
Buy that was my backup plan if YouTube
didn't work okay I can just go get a job
at Best Buy and I'll have this awesome
resume of some cool tech videos on
YouTube yeah but it's it's hard to
imagine doing something else at this
point it really is it's weird to think
about what no this is I think you'll
definitely have a good answer for this
one what's your favorite music album cuz
I guess you probably I know what your
guess is already do your guesses Ram by
- yes and that is definitely a top three
boy oh there's some albums I like to
listen to in there completion okay that
have a lot of replay value so I'll give
the time I'll just I already know the
incredible true story by logic I don't
necessarily listen to individual songs
on that album as much as I just listen
to the whole thing about you favorite
album uh okay yeah no that's that's an
easy one I think RAM is probably my top
5 but incredible true story I've
listened to so many times like every
year when I go to my spotify you're in a
wine flight people like fadeaways like I
was like number one you know it's weird
though okay so and I didn't even
remember this but when I go back in that
Spotify year and rewind for the past two
at least maybe three years my number one
artist is always Kanye and I didn't
realize how many years of Kanye albums
I've listened to from like college
dropout to graduation that whole time
it's not really that much new Kanye but
there's a lot so I'll throw I'll toss
graduation in there for I can get behind
that except there's a lot of Kanye that
I think would be on like my top ten yeah
when was the last time a tech item blew
your mind blew my mind I actually blew
your mind my answer is in the frame
right now yeah
auto pilot not necessarily like the
actual car but there is something weird
about when you're driving being able to
actually take your hands off the wheel
and actually do something else
I was messed with my parents in this
picked them up from the airport during a
holiday and my sister was in on it but
she's like hey can't grab some from the
backseat and I'm an auto pilot I just
kind of casually reached back and the
cars and they're in the backseat like
what is he doing
hilarious I'm definitely gonna do some
more some more Tesla videos and you'll
see model three video coming very soon
forgot to hold mention that whole thing
but that's coming coming pretty quick so
auto pilots on my list what do you got
you know I can't think of a better
answer than that I was probably gonna
say something dumb but like honestly
autopilot you're right it's like such a
crazy sort of feature because you think
how much time do you spend driving and
it's just like you hit a button she's
like oh yeah the cars you can do this
for me it's great this car the fact that
this car is built on autonomous
ride-sharing should say something about
the way car tech has gone in the future
so I'll leave it at that
thank you for participating in my Q&A
hopefully you guys enjoy the questions
and the answers I thought they were
pretty solid but stay tuned of course
for the Tesla video and for many more
things to come the Q&A is every month
that's over on Twitter if you're not
already following follow this guy he
makes YouTube videos also and he makes
he makes tweets sometimes very gonna
read this thanks for watching talk to
guys the next one peace